en vídeos anteriores vimos el concepto
de lo que es una función de densidad de
probabilidad y también vimos la idea de
variable aleatoria y también vimos que
hay de dos tipos verdad esencialmente
tenemos la variable aleatoria que es
discreta verdad y cuando decimos que es
discreta se refiere a que tiene un
número finito de valores o lo más que
puede tener es digamos una cantidad
infinita que se puede enumerar verdad
por ejemplo 1 2 3 4 y así seguimos de
forma indefinida esa es la variable
aleatoria discreta que esencialmente es
la que tiene una cantidad finita de
valores y que a veces quizás muy de
forma muy común suele tener valores
enteros verdad pero no necesariamente
puede tener otro tipo de valores y
además de la variable aleatoria discreta
tenemos la variable aleatoria continua
continua muy bien y esencialmente vamos
a trabajar este concepto de la de la
variable aleatoria continua en este
vídeo y vamos a hacerlo mejor
con un ejemplo digamos que tenemos la
siguiente variable aleatoria
y uso ye para que no siempre se vea qué
bueno que se vea que pueden ser
distintas letras no siempre tiene que
ser x verdad y digamos que ya es la
cantidad exacta de lluvia ok la cantidad
exacta de lluvia y estoy pensando en
lluvia porque en la ciudad de méxico ha
estado lloviendo muy a menudo en estos
días entonces pensemos que jesse a la
cantidad exacta de lluvia de mañana
digamos del día de mañana
ok esa va a ser nuestra variable
aleatoria y en principio no conozco la
función de densidad que describe esta
esta variable aleatoria pero pero voy a
dibujar una y vamos vamos a
interpretarla ok entonces vamos a hacer
unos ejes digamos aquí tengo
voy a hacer una línea digamos que aquí
tengo un eje
y aquí tengo el otro eje
ahí están y digamos que aquí en el eje x
vamos a medir digamos la lluvia
la lluvia
y esta se mide en milímetros verdad y
digamos que hay acá arriba estamos
midiendo la probabilidad probabilidad
o bueno quizás vamos a dejarlo solo así
y vamos a dejar la gráfica que va a
representar esto ok vamos a pintar la
quizás sea
así
muy bien o que quizás debería ser un
dibujo un poco más más preciso
que puede elevarse por aquí
y después la gráfica seguirse hasta el
infinito aproximándose al eje muy bien
entonces esta es digamos la gráfica de
la función de densidad de probabilidad
ok vamos a vamos a escribir eso esta es
la densidad
densidad de probabilidad
y esta es la gráfica muy bien digamos
que aquí está el no sé a lo mejor aquí
está un milímetro de lluvia a lo mejor
aquí están dos milímetros de lluvia tres
milímetros de lluvia cuatro milímetros
de lluvia y así sucesivamente muy bien
entonces este ejemplo está hecho para
que podamos ver cómo cómo vamos a pensar
las variables aleatorias continuas muy
bien y con esto podríamos tratar de
pensar por ejemplo cuál es la
probabilidad cuál es la probabilidad de
que la cantidad exacta de lluvia de
mañana sea exactamente 2 milímetros ok
ya lo mejor tú podrías decir bueno pues
si esto es 2 milímetros y a lo mejor
esta es digamos la altura y que la
altura sea 0.5 tú podrías pensar a lo
mejor que pues digamos
aquí esta es la altura que a lo mejor
está probabilidad es de 0.5
podría ser que sea de 0.5 y bueno la
respuesta es que no no es la forma
adecuada de interpretar una variable a
la aleatoria continua y vamos a pensar
primero de forma lógica y luego lo
veremos de forma continua por ejemplo el
resultado de la lluvia digamos del día
de mañana después de medir cuánta lluvia
cayó en la ciudad de mexico podríamos
pensar que o más bien podría podría
haber sido 2.01 verdad o puede ser que
mañana llueva 1.99 milímetros de lluvia
o alomejor 1.999 999 milímetros de
lluvia o por el contrario podrían ser
2.000 01 milímetros de lluvia verdad
entonces todos estos resultados no son
válidos nosotros queremos la
probabilidad de que la cantidad de
lluvia sea exactamente de 2 milímetros
verdad no queremos ni un átomo de agua
por encima de la marca de 2 milímetros
ni un solo átomo entonces si te pones a
pensar en eso
la probabilidad de que sea exactamente 2
es casi cero verdad porque digo no es no
es obvio porque a lo mejor escuchas muy
a menudo que tuvimos dos milímetros de
lluvia o algo por el estilo verdad y lo
que pasa es que generalmente si la gente
obtiene no sea un resultado de 2.01 pues
la gente suele redondear y dice que son
dos milímetros pero esto en realidad no
cuenta para lo que estamos haciendo en
nuestro ejercicio verdad 2.01 no son dos
milímetros de lluvia tampoco 1.99 son
dos milímetros de lluvia ok de hecho
ninguno de estos números que obtuvimos
digamos son los dos que nosotros
queremos así que puedes pensar que la
probabilidad de que la cantidad exacta
de lluvia de mañana sea 2 es cero
ok y bueno todavía tenemos otro problema
verdad nuestros instrumentos de medición
no son exactos no distinguen digamos los
átomos que sobran cuando estamos
midiendo los milímetros de lluvia oa lo
mejor no son precisos tienen algunos
errores muy bien entonces si no podemos
hacerlo de esta forma cuál sería la
forma correcta de pensar la probabilidad
de una variable aleatoria continua y
entonces tenemos que pensar por ejemplo
cuál es la probabilidad de que ya sea
casi 2 y eso lo podemos escribir de la
siguiente forma cuál es la probabilidad
de que llegue menos 2 en valor absoluto
es decir cuál es la desviación que tiene
la variable y el respecto de la cantidad
2 sea más chica que por ejemplo una una
cantidad de tolerancia no sé un 0.1
verdad ya lo mejor esto te causa
conflicto bueno pues esto es lo mismo es
una forma equivalente de decir que ya se
encuentre entre 1.9
y 2.1 que ya sea mayor que 1.9 y menor
que 2.1 entonces en este caso lo que
tenemos que hacer es nos fijamos en 2
nos fijamos en 1.9 y en 2.1 verdad y
entonces queremos ver todos estos
valores
todos estos todos éstos deberían debería
pintarlo un poco mejor con una línea
todos estos valores ok todo esto que
está debajo de la gráfica es lo que nos
interesa si queremos saber la
probabilidad de que ye se encuentre por
arriba de 1.9 y por debajo de 2.1
esencialmente se convierte en un
problema de encontrar el área debajo de
la curva verdad por ejemplo si nosotros
pensamos que esta curva que estoy ahora
remarcando con verde
no importa es la curva más o menos se
observa si pensamos que esta curva está
dada por la gráfica de la función f x
donde f x pues no sé la es una función
particular entonces esta área debajo de
la curva entre 1.9 y 2.1 es y esto
seguramente ya lo conocen los que han
llevado cálculo es la integral desde 1.9
a 2.1 de la función f x verdad estamos
integrando la función en este intervalo
muy bien y esto es muy importante si una
variable aleatoria puede tomar digamos
cualquier valor en un intervalo entonces
la probabilidad de que tome un valor
exacto es práctica es cero es es
exactamente cero verdad esto por
supuesto es equivalente a preguntarnos
cuál sería el área verdad el área de una
recta si nosotros tenemos una línea así
que si nosotros tenemos una línea así
cuál es el área de esta línea bueno pues
nosotros sabemos que el área podría ser
algo así como la longitud de la base por
la altura y la altura pues si tendrá
alguna pero no tiene base de verdad la
longitud de su base es cero muy bien y
por supuesto que no es la única forma de
pensar
la probabilidad verdad por ejemplo qué
tal que nos preguntáramos cuál es la
probabilidad de que la cantidad exacta
de lluvia de mañana se encuentra entre 1
y 3 sea mayor que un milímetro y menor
que tres milímetros entonces tendríamos
que calcular el área debajo de la curva
entre estos dos valores verdad entre
estos dos valores y calculamos esta área
también podríamos pensar por ejemplo
cuál es la probabilidad de que la
cantidad exacta de lluvia de mañana se
encuentre sea menor que 0.1 verdad
entonces y aquí está el 0.1
aunque entonces estaríamos pensando en
todos los valores entre 0 y 0.1 también
podríamos pensar bueno cuál es la
probabilidad de que la cantidad de
lluvia de mañana sea mayor que 4
milímetros entonces nosotros tendríamos
que calcular el área debajo de esta
curva desde 4 hasta infinito hasta
infinito y tú estarás pensando bueno
cómo es posible que eso sea un número
bueno puede ser que si puede ser que si
vamos sumando toda esta área nos dé
puede ser no sé del 10% o algo por el
estilo y quizás esta misma idea ya te
esté hablando de algo muy importante por
ejemplo cuál es la probabilidad de que
la variable aleatoria tome un valor
entre 0 e infinito pues sería toda el
área debajo
curva verdad toda toda toda el área todo
del área entonces eso debe ser un número
muy particular verdad porque ya puede
tomar un valor entre 0 e infinito verdad
y la probabilidad de que tome un valor
verdad con cualquier valor de todos los
que puede tomar pues es una verdad
siempre va a tomar un valor particular
así que eso nos dice que la integral
desde cero a este infinito o bien el
área debajo de la curva de fx de x tiene
que ser exactamente 1 verdad esto es lo
mismo que es lo mismo que decir que la
probabilidad de que se tome un valor
entre 0 infinita pues es una verdad
siempre tiene que tomar al menos un
valor muy bien y esto quizás no sea tan
obvio para ti si no has visto
probabilidad perdón cálculo temas de
cálculo pero bueno solo recuerda que la
integral de una función es el área
debajo de esa curva y esta misma idea no
sólo es para las variables aleatorias
continuas también podríamos trabajar
para las variables aleatorias discretas
por ejemplo si tenemos el experimento
del del volado que déjenme hacer algo de
este estilo que digamos que tenemos una
variable aleatoria x que vale 0 si al
digamos al hacer un volado sale como
resultado sol y vale 1 si sale águila
muy bien entonces en nuestra gráfica
digamos que vamos a hacer aquí tenemos
el valor 0 que pues tiene cierta
probabilidad de que salga de que salga
sol y hay cierta probabilidad de que
salga águila verdad hay cierta
probabilidad de que salga águila
entonces el punto es que la probabilidad
de que salga sol más la probabilidad de
que salga águila tiene que ser una
verdad entonces no se esté típicamente
en un volado pues esto será 0.5 y ambos
son 0.5 verdad si tenemos 0.5
+ 0.5 nos da 1 no necesariamente tiene
que ser 0.5 por ejemplo éste podría ser
el 60% y entonces este de aquí tendría
que ser 40 verdad no podría ser 60
también porque 60 más 60 nos da un 120%
y eso no tiene sentido verdad entonces
este lo equivalente a decir que la
integral de nuestra función desde cero
infinito es igual a 1 solo que el otro
caso es para variable
aleatoria discreta y bueno ya se me está
acabando el tiempo pero en los próximos
vídeos hablaremos sobre la esperanza o
el valor esperado de una variable
aleatoria